4,2% des accidents mortels sur
autoroutes sont directement liée au
pneumatiques c'est ce qui ressort d'une
enquête se menée par l'institut BVA et
je reçois Jean Yves petit bonsoir vous
êtes le directeur du comité des Yvelines
de la prévention routière du 10 au 15
juin se déroule la semaine du pneu c'est
une première elle les automobilistes
sont attendus sans rendez-vous dans près
de 2000 centres 1781 centre partenaires
pour faire vérifier gratuitement l'état
de leur pneumatique on va évoquer ce
dossier auparavant je voudrais juste
votre réaction puisque l'information
était communiquée dans l'après-midi et
c'est un chiffre c'est la chute du
nombre de tués sur les routes moins
29,5% sur les routes en mai 2013 par
rapport à mai 2012 ce qui représente 266
personnes malgré tout tout de même
est-ce que ce chiffre vous le jugez déjà
bon est-ce que dans les Yvelines la
situation est la même alors sur le plan
national ce chiffre s'explique par une
raison que j'avais déjà évoquée je crois
quand je suis venu chez vous on a un
accident quand il fait beau
au mois de mai il a fait un temps
déplorable comme tout le monde le sait
et donc les gens sortent pas et en
particulier les deux roues dans les
Yvelines nous avons eu au mois de mai un
accident mortel enfin un mort au mois
d'avril il y en avait une neuf mais
globalement dans les Yvelines depuis le
début de l'année nous sommes
malheureusement plus mauvais que la
moyenne nationale nous déplorons
aujourd'hui 22 tués depuis le début de
l'année alors que l'année dernière elle
n'avait pas qu'il n'y en avait que 16
dans notre département et l'une des
causes de ces accidents c'est le mauvais
état des pneumatiques alors je ne sais
pas si c'est à jouer sur les premiers
accidents de ce début d'année en tout
cas je le disais tout à l'heure au
niveau national c'est 4,2% des accidents
mortels sur autoroute qui sont liés au
mauvais état de des pneumatiques la
prévention routière a donc décidé de se
mobiliser sur ce dossier là oui alors
pas uniquement la prévention routière
bien sûr la prévention routière en
collaboration avec les professionnels le
syndicat des professionnels du pneu donc
nous lançons comme vous l'avez dit une
opération semaine du pneu de contrôle
des gratuits des pneus comme vous l'avez
annoncé sur quatre aspect le gonflage
l'usure l'équilibrage et la roue de
secours donc comme vous l'avez dit les
gens peuvent aller gratuitement dans les
dans les centres dont ils trouveront la
localisation par internet et faire au
moins un diagnostic gratuit après les
réparations évidemment sont payantes
mais le diagnostic est gratuit c'est pas
un partenariat avec donc le syndicat des
professionnels est-ce que pour autant le
but c'est d'inciter les gens a changé
leur pneus non pas forcément alors
est-ce qu'il faut
les gens qui pourraient se dire voilà je
vais aller me rendre dans un centre
faire le contrôle des pneus alors
forcément on va me demander de les
changer même s'il y a pas besoin alors
ça j'avoue que je veux pas rentrer dans
ce comme la prévention routière est
associée
je ne veux pas rentrer là-dedans bien
sûr mais après donc les professionnels
vont faire un diagnostic et après chacun
sera face à ses responsabilités mais il
est vrai que aujourd'hui des pneus ça
coûte cher il faut bien reconnaître et
donc environ 20% des personnes attendent
que l'usure des pneus soit largement
au-delà de la limite pour les changer
donc on roule avec des pneus
complètement lisses quoi parce que il
est vrai que les pneus coûte cher mais
il y va de la sécurité
forcément avec la seule en contact avec
la route on va peut-être donner aussi
quelques conseils parce qu'il y a ce
contrôle à effectuer aux cadres dans le
cadre de cette semaine du pneu ce
diagnostic sera gratuit dans les dans
les centres partenaires mais par exemple
combien de kilomètres on peut rouler
avec un pneu quels sont les les états
d'alerte qu'on peut se poser les voyants
qu'il faut garder en tête alors
maintenant alors moi je ne suis pas un
spécialiste du pneu premièrement les
gens proposer des questions quand ils
iront chez les professionnels
l'usure vous savez que il y a des
petites marques dans la dans la
sculpture et les l'usure doit rester au
minimum de 1,6 mm au-delà le pneu est
considéré comme usé et donc dangereux ça
augmente la distance de freinage la
distance de freinage c'est évidemment
quelque chose de très important donc la
distance de freinage est augmentée en
cas en cas de pneu usé
maintenant beaucoup de voitures modernes
sont équipés de d'options vous savez des
alarmes quand les pneus sont sous
gonflés par exemple donc c'est
évidemment encouragé ce sont des options
qui coûtent peut-être un peu de sous
c'est évident qu'il n'y a pas participé
également tout ça est très important on
va continuer à en parler encore pendant
quelques instants sur ce plateau juste
après ce micro-trottoir faites-vous
attention à l'état de vos pneumatiques
sur la route voici la réponse je laisse
ça à faire à mon mari il regarde tous
les niveaux et la pression de mes pneus
pas tous les mois mais enfin de temps en
temps en vacances moi non mon mari oui
chaque fois qu'on part en vacances donc
on est un autre agent à faire voilà tous
les mois une fois par mois à peu près
parce que je fais un peu d'autoroute
pour la économiser le carburant le
diesel
oui je la vérifie parce que je veux pas
avoir l'accident
et j'ai même un appareil de pression
chez moi donc je vérifie régulièrement
si vous avez toujours des pneus qui sont
bien bien gonflés correctement vous avez
une usure beaucoup moins oui je faisais
souvent effectivement j'ai une petite
pompe à la maison avec un manomètre et
comme je suis motard aussi et ben
effectivement on a un peu plus sensible
à ça en tant que motard
les usagers de la route qui font
attention visiblement dans les
micro-trottoirs on a eu de la chance je
sais pas si c'est représentatif mais en
tout cas les gens font attention et on a
entendu aussi dans le dernier
micro-trottoir dernière personne qui est
intervenue ça concerne aussi les motos
oui bien sûr parce que aussi sont
concernés
d'homme voilà effectivement c'est
peut-être l'enseignement de ce
micro-trottoir alors je cite et tout à
l'heure ce chiffre 24,2 % des accidents
mortels sur autoroute lié automatique
cette enquête BVA révèle d'autres
enseignements 78% des automobilistes et
qui vérifier régulièrement la pression
comme les téléspectateurs que nous avons
rencontrés en revanche ils sont aussi
74% à vouloir faire durer plus longtemps
leur pneumatique voire en différé le
changement même s'ils sont à la limite
d'usure pour 21% d'entre eux ça c'est
aussi peut-être l'effet l'effet crise
elle est faite que le budget soit soit
élevé c'est ce que nous disions il y a
un instant oui c'est vrai on a évoqué
effectivement ce problème d'usure il y a
le sous le surgonflage il faut vérifier
régulièrement quel conseil vous pouvez
donner pour la prévention il faut
vérifier le gonflage de ces pneus tous
les mois tous les mois c'est ce qui est
recommandé et évidemment à l'occasion de
des départs en vacances ou quand on va
faire de longs trajets sur autoroute par
exemple c'est absolument nécessaire
comme l'a dit un des personnes par
micro-trottoir
ça participe aussi d'une bonne d'une
économie de d'essence quand les pneus
sont bien gonflés on consomme moins que
quand ils sont sous gonflés et pour
qu'on fait justement ces pneus quel
moment il faut s'y prendre est-ce que il
faut que il faut que les pneus soient
froids il faut que les deux soient
froids bien sûr vous faites bien de me
le faire rappeler il faut le faire le
plus tôt possible quand on quand on
prend quand on prend sa voiture bien sûr
ça aussi c'est important et puis autre
conseil route secours et équilibrage
aussi parce que la campagne de
sensibilisation de prévention porte
aussi sur ces deux points absolument oui
alors l'équilibrage ça ça joue sur
l'usure des pneus bien sûr
donc il faut faire contrôler
l'équilibrage ça ça se fait au contrôle
technique pour les voitures d'occasion
et pour les voitures neuves
théoriquement il y en a pas besoin avec
cette semaine là c'est l'occasion de
faire contrôler l'équilibrage
qui influe sur l'usure des pneus aussi
la bonne usure des pneus semaine de
sensibilisation jusqu'au 15 juin près de
2100 à travers la France partenaire on
peut faire vérifier gratuitement ces
pneumatiques il aura d'autres opérations
qui concernera qui concerneront pardon
pas forcément les pneus qui seront menés
par la prévention routière d'ici les
grandes vacances alors oui pour les
vacances je vous les signaler deux
opérations enfin une qui est pas
réellement une opération mais qui est
dans notre site internet il s'appelle
voyager en Europe dans notre site
internet on trouve 16 fiches pour 16
pays avec la réglementation dans ces
pays par exemple en Espagne il faut deux
triangles et un gilet par personne en
Croatie qui est une autre destination
d'été pas d'alcool pour les moins de 25
ans et feux de croisement allumé jour et
nuit voilà il y a donc c'est
réglementations voilà pour pour 18 pays
nous avons une fiche comme ça que que
les téléspectateurs peuvent trouver les
internautes peuvent trouver dans notre
dans notre site Internet et deuxièmement
une opération qui concerne le mois de
juillet qui s'appelle visible l'été donc
pour faire prendre conscience aux gens
que à la fois le soleil et le mauvais
état ou le mauvais nettoyage des
pare-brise sont là aussi cause
d'accident
645 accidents du à la au soleil ou à la
réverbération l'année dernière donc
cette opération en partenariat avec
Chris et Carglass les gens qui ont des
travaux à faire chez Carglass auront en
cadeau une paire de lunettes de soleil à
verres polarisant et puis également un
bon de réduction de 50 euros pour un
prochain achat chez Chris
mais en tout cas c'est pour la bonne
cause puisque l'objectif c'est bien
évidemment de réduire ses accidents sur
la route merci d'être venu sur ce
plateau nous parlions routière depuis
quelques instants